let me ask you the ridiculous big
question who do you think is the
greatest football
aka soccer player of all time can you
make the case for messi can you make the
case for cristiano ronaldo
pele maradona does somebody anybody jump
to mind
i think it's pretty hard to make a case
for
anybody else
than messi for his uh for his all-around
game
and uh
frankly like my
real madrid fandom sort of
uh predates the ronaldo
era era uh this the second ronaldo not
not not the first one so i always liked
ronaldo but i always kind of thought
that
messi was
was better and
i went to quite a number of madrid games
and they've always been super helpful to
me down there the only thing is that
like they asked me they were gonna do an
interview and they were gonna ask me who
my favorite player was and
um
i said somebody else i think i said isko
at that point and i was like okay take
two now you say ronaldo
so for them it was um
it was very important but it wasn't
wasn't that huge to um
to me so messy over maradona
yeah but it's i think
just like with chess it's hard to
compare eras
obviously the improvements in football
have been like
in in technique and such have been even
greater than they have been in in in
chess but it's um
it's always um it's always a really
weird discussion uh to have but just as
a fan what do you
think is
beautiful about the game what defines
greatness is it
you know with messi
one he's really good at finishing
two very good at assists
like three there's just magic it's just
beautiful to see the play so it's not
just about the finishing there's some
it's like mardon's hand of god there's
some
creativity
on the pitch is is that important or is
it very important to get the world cups
and the big championships and that kind
of stuff i think the world cup is pretty
pretty overrated seeing us um as it's uh
such a small sample size so
uh
uh it sort of annoys me always when you
know titles are always um
always appreciated so much
even though
that particular title can be
can be a lot of a lot of
luck or at least some
at least some luck um
so i do appreciate um
statistics a bit and all the statistics
say that mess is
the best finisher of all time which i
think helps a lot
and then there's the intangibles as well
the flip side of that is the small
sample size
is what
really
creates the magic
it's sober it's just like the olympics
you you basically train your whole life
for this you live your whole life for
this and it's a rare moment one mistake
and it's all over
that's
for some reason a lot of people
either break under that pressure or rise
up under that pressure you know you
don't admire the magic of that no i i do
i just think that like rising and
to the pressure and breaking on the
under the pressure is often a really
oversimplified
like
uh taken on what's um on what's
happening
yeah we do romanticize the game yeah
well let me ask you another ridiculous
question another you're also a fan of
basketball
yes
let me ask the goat question do you i
you know i'm biased because uh i went to
high school in chicago
uh you know chicago bulls during the
michael jordan era uh let me ask the the
jordan versus lebron james question
let's let's continue on this thread of
greatness which one do you pick or
somebody else
so i'll give you a completely different
answer uh-oh um
depending on my mood and depending who
on whom i talk to i pick one of one of
the two and then i tried to argue it's
the quantum mechanical thing well can
you what
again what
what would uh if you were to argue for
either one
statistically i think lebron james is
going to surpass jordan yeah no doubt
and so
again there's a
debate between
unquantifiable greatness no that i mean
that's the whole that's the whole debate
yes so it's well it's quantifiable
versus unquantifiable yeah what's more
important and you're depending on mood
all over the place
but what do you lean in general with
these with these folks with with soccer
with anything in life
towards the unquantifiable more no
definitely towards the quantifiable so
when you're unsure lean towards the
numbers yeah but see like it's later
generations
there's something that's what people say
about maradona is you know he took uh
arguably somewhat mediocre team
to a world cup
so there's that also uplifting nature of
the player to be able to rise up the
whole it is a team sport so are you
gonna like are you gonna punish um
messi for
taking a mediocre argentine squad to to
the to the final in 2014 and punish him
because they lost to
a great team very narrowly after they
missed
he set up like a great chance for iguain
in the first half which he
um which he fluffed and then yeah
eventually they lost the game
yeah they do criticize cristiano ronaldo
messi for being on really strong squads
in terms of the club
teams and saying yeah okay it's easy
when you have like ronaldinho or whoever
on your team
it would be very interesting just uh if
the league could make a
decision
yeah just random random allocation yeah
um
and just every single game just keep
relocating or maybe once a season um or
every season you get random but let's
say every
every player
um
if let's say they sign a five-year
contract for a team like one of them
you're going to get randomly allocated
to
to let's say a bottom half team
i bet you there's going to be so much
corruption around that it'll be not
obviously it wouldn't
ever happen or or work but i think it's
if you never know first thing to think
about
you